there are videos that speak for themselves
attention
who you are going to vote for next Sunday,
July 23rd
to Vox what do you like about Vox
is Spanish Spanish
as if the rest of the matches were French
the Portuguese
or as if to be Spanish
was 1 measure of 1 electoral program
what to do with healthcare Spain
what to do with taxes on the rich Spain
what to do with abortion or LGTBI rights
Spain I translate it for you
privatizing healthcare and lowering taxes on the wealthy
abortion and burden mgtbi rights
but they are embarrassed to say it and only say Spain
but expect there to be more
the current government of Pedro
um what do you think
eh I don't like it very much
good acceptable review
did not like it at all
not the laws
only if it is yes,
stray aerosols Such eh
eh eh anyway everything is said don't you think?
next July 23rd
remember that these people always vote in Spain